Very rare public
admission from the Russian president.
More than 15 months
into his war of choice,
Putin confirms
his military is short on high
position ammunition
as well as attack drones.
Putin says the Russian weapon
quality is improving
and the defense industry
is improving output.
But more equipment, he says, is needed
for Georgia.
It's only one imperative.
Still,
of course,
during the special military operation,
it became clear
that we don't have enough of some things.
These are high precision
munitions, communications equipment, UAV,
yes, drone aircraft.
We have them.
Unfortunately, we need
greater quantities.
Steve Hall is a CNN national security
analyst and former
chief of Russia operations for the CIA.
It's good to see you, Steve.
Thanks for being with us.
Sure. Great to be here.
Okay, so
in the spirit of always look
on the bright side of life,
here's a little more
from the Russian president.
Listen to this.
Almost next year.
Our production is growing.
Performance is growing.
Range and accuracy are increasing.
If it had not been
for the special military operation,
we would never have understood
how to fine tune
our military production
so that our army
is the best in the world.
But we will do it.
So the bullet all down
Russia is short on ammunition
and other material.
Domestic production
capacity was woefully overestimated.
And the range and accuracy of the weapons
they have needs improvement.
On the bright side,
at least they now know that
it's almost like he's
been in therapy, right?
I mean, the therapist says, yeah,
there's a lot of bad things going on.
But, you know, there's
at least this one bright thing of course,
we can't really believe any of that
because it's coming from the Kremlin.
But the very idea that, well,
thank goodness
this special military operation, a.k.a.
war, happened because now
at least
we know
where we need to improve
on the already
best military in the world.
I mean, it just doesn't make any sense.
It's almost babbling.
So why would he come
out and do this then?
Yeah, that's the big question.
I mean,
so if you get to the
to the question as to
why is this happening?
I mean, it's obvious
that sanctions are having an impact.
They can't get the electronics
that they need for some of their
some of their high tech weaponry.
So, you know,
that's sort of the simple question
I think most people understand.
For me,
the really fascinating question is
why does Vladimir Putin choose
to address this?
And I think, again,
we have to turn to history in Russia.
There have been so many Russian leaders
who, after a failed
or stalemated war,
did not survive in power afterward.
I wonder whether Putin or not Putin
is thinking about that,
whether he's beginning to see, okay,
I'm not going to win it.
The best I can hope for
is some kind of draw,
some sort of frozen conflict.
But if that happens,
how will I survive politically?
And I wonder whether or not he's
trying
to prepare
the Russian population
for that eventuality.
And trying to try to figure out
a soft landing for himself.
And the initial Russian invasion
force here into Ukraine
was around, what, 120,000 troops,
maybe more a year on 100,000 of either
being killed or wounded.
That seems to be
an extraordinary high price to pay
to find out your military kind of sucks.
Yes.
Well, and even worse.
So not only not only have
you found out all the horrible things
that your own military,
you know, can't even pull off,
can't even can't even really run a war.
You've managed to pull together
your primary enemy, Naito in the West
in a way,
in a unification
that we just haven't seen in decades.
I mean,
Naito has never been more unified,
certainly in the past.
It's taking on new,
really powerful members.
And you have really,
really put your country
into Vladimir Putin
in a very bad position.
And he's got to be thinking okay,
how am I going to get out of this
if I can't win it,
which it's not looking like I can't.
And with that assessment
that you just made,
let's listen to
comments made by the US
President Joe Biden.
On Tuesday. Here he is.
Putin is making a mistake.
He is looking for the
finalization of Naito.
He got the position of Finland
and hopefully Sweden very shortly
So does that essentially sum
up the essence of Putin's
biggest miscalculation here?
You know,
at this point
it's it's
kind of difficult to say
which is which is the worst?
Which is the biggest.
I mean, certainly if you believe Putin
and I think that there is some validity
in Russians
in Russia's concern about naito.
Yes, it's a defensive alliance.
But in Russia's mind, it's
just this massive enemy that's out there.
But does that mean that you
then take steps
that are going to make that enemy
even stronger,
more unified, richer, bigger?
That's a huge mistake.
Let alone, you know, all the other
relatively smaller things
that are happening,
like your military
is incapable of performing
all the Russian lives that are lost.
Not that Putin cares
that much about those things,
but it's just this litany of mistakes
and again, you got to wonder,
where is his way out of it?
How does he end up
at the end of all of this?
Well, Putin had this
take on how the war could actually end.
Here he is
used and used to be allocated.
The key to solve
the problem is on their side.
If they really want today's conflict
to resolve via talks,
they just need to take a single decision.
Stop supplying arms.
That's it.
Ukraine does
not produce anything themselves.
If by talks, he means Ukraine's
total surrender
by not being armed and
supplied by the West,
well, then he's right.
But it almost sounds kind of pelting
in a way
that he feels robbed of the victory
because of NATO's US support for Ukraine.
Yeah, I mean, as usual, this is
actually this is something
that's much
more usual that comes out of the Kremlin
when we hear him say things
that are pretty much
the exact opposite
of what actual truth is.
So, you know,
who can end the war tomorrow?
Vladimir Putin, by simply
withdrawing troops
from the company
that is the country
that he chose to invade.
So you know, to turn that on its head
and say, well,
you know,
the Ukrainians in the West could end this
if they simply stop supplying weapons,
you know, is
it sort of sort of ludicrous
the easy and obvious thing to do is on
the Russian
side would be
if you really want to stop the war,
just withdraw your forces.
But of course, geopolitically
and internally for Putin,
that's
not a viable option
if he wants to survive,
if he wants his regime to survive.
Yeah.
He has not created
quite a mess, to say the least.
Steven Hall is always good to be with us.
Thank you.